[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily
i'm sorry for what i did but that
apology from an admitted killer
did not spare him the wrath of a
grieving father whose daughter was taken
at age 23. rapper offset records himself
in this scuffle with the police
and authorities make their first legal
moves in a lawsuit involving the deadly
chopper crash
which killed kobe bryant plus a massive
sex crimes bust in ohio
sex trafficking may appear to be a
victimless crime but it's not
more than 150 are under arrest more than
100 victims
are rescued law and crime daily covers
court cases from coast to coast
and welcome to lawn crime daily
everybody i'm erin keller along with
brian buckmeyer and terry austin
authorities in ohio announcing the
results of a massive sex crimes bust
called operation autumn hope
the operation seen here in video
released to the attorney general's
office
resulted in the arrests of 157 men
across southern ohio
109 victims were rescued and 76
missing and exploited children cases
were cleared
of the 76 children 45 were recovered
through the assistance
of the u.s marshals service at the
federal level ohio's attorney general
described one of the women authorities
rescued
who has three children and a fourth on
the way after being trafficked for sex
for five years going back to when she
was 16.
when we picked her up she told us that
she was doing a gram and a half
a day of fentanyl
and crack cocaine just so she didn't get
sick that wasn't to get high that was to
keep her from getting
addiction sickness
she was pregnant and was continuing to
use even though
she hated herself for
continuing to feed her addiction while
she was pregnant
during the course of her five-year
journey
she's been beaten over and over
she's been assaulted with a gun
raped multiple times that's why this
operation
this law enforcement operation was
called operation hope that's why some of
the people you're going to hear from
today
don't wear a badge but they carry a
helping hand
and a tool kit to help the survivors of
human trafficking to
try to reclaim their life
and it's why the rest of us society
should care a lot about this
the columbus police department was
responsible for 80 arrests
from the streets of our neighborhoods to
the dark corners of the internet
this year operation hope autumn hope
brought together almost 60 agencies
making this the largest operation to
combat human trafficking i believe in
the history of ohio
our street level operations in columbus
focused on those neighborhoods where
prostitution is visible
in those neighborhoods those involved
are caught in a cycle of addiction
and abuse and those that profit prey
upon this vulnerable population the
central ohio human trafficking task
force worked
to provide victims with resources but
even more importantly
they identified traffickers and they're
working to build cases that will
take them off the street
the sheriff of franklin county ohio
which surrounds columbus describes
several of the defendants his department
arrested they arrested eight men who
traveled to central ohio area
for one purpose and that was to have sex
with a child
now what's a little surprising is of
these eight men
virtually nobody had any remorse they
were very blatant they were defiant
as an example one of them actually
linked with the cameras who was being
arrested
and led off well in the sheriff's office
we have a very
important message anybody wants to come
to central ohio and pray on our children
we're watching we're we'll catch you and
we will put you in jail
as the ag said several groups of
advocates are working with the women
and in some cases children who were
rescued
they shared stories that were full of
fear
and torment and anguish
but also stories of strength hope and
resiliency
we remind survivors that what happened
to them was never their fault
and they deserve to be believed and
supported
and have access to justice they do not
fit a one-size-fits-all description
there are certainly themes and trends in
the lives of many women in this
situation but they're also unique
and special and they have varying
experiences of trauma
varying motivations for why they're in
the life in the first place
and varying needs it's easy to think of
a typical scenario
when interacting with a woman to think
you know her story
and to cease being curious and this is
why in my opinion
we have to slow down we have to let our
assumptions go
pay attention ask good questions and
listen
another bizarre sex crimes case out of
ohio involving alleged human trafficking
involving a criminal defense attorney
michael moran faces 18 felony counts
including
racketeering trafficking in persons and
promoting prostitution
ohio's attorney general tweeted photos
of moran's arrest recently
the allegations involved crimes against
six victims spanning
15 years we asked the ag about this case
today and he says
it's different because moran used his
knowledge of the criminal justice system
to traffic women
the defense lawyer's favorite trick in
one of these cases
is to to tear apart the credibility
of the survivor who's trying to tell her
story
and usually it's pretty easy to do she's
usually got a rap sheet
she may has have a drug or alcohol
problem
probably has some things in her past
that helped
lead to her vulnerability and her trauma
that was exploited
in the era of me too prosecutions have
changed
because people to do this over and over
again leave behind
them a tale that is told
over and over again by women who do not
know each other
and when they all tell the same story
with same
salient points then you can't rip
apart their credibility as easy
a defense attorney appeared in court
this afternoon he's being held on three
hundred thousand dollars bond so
terry brian let's jump in here and
discuss this terry i got to ask this
what
impresses me about this announcement is
not just the legal activity but the
focus on services for the victims that
was a big part
of what we heard from the authorities i
was impressed too aaron because this is
a broad-based initiative
it absolutely focuses on the victims and
it recuses them actually
from the crime of human trafficking and
it refers them to
social services so it really is trying
to focus on not just the criminal act
but the victims themselves
and it really does help recover missing
and exploited children so
i think it's a really broad-based
initiative that is going to help in the
state
it's similar to some other initiatives
we talked about recently involving other
states such as georgia
brian i got to ask about this other case
though involving the defense attorney i
felt like the ag
took a pretty heavy-handed swipe at
defense attorneys in general just
because
he says he caught one particular bad
apple in his words his allegations
yeah and i think he has to give a hand a
heavy-handed approach sorry at that
because the reality is is that he's
using the criminal justice system
that is promulgated by the prosecutor to
go after
the johns or the actual victims of this
crime i welcome
all prosecutors to finally join on the
side of public defenders who have been
representing
these women that are victims of sex
trafficking of slavery
these victims know no class no race they
can be victims in any way shape or form
and it's about time that prosecutors
start treating them like victims rather
than
defend into small level crimes so
certainly much more to discuss as these
cases move through the court system
we'll be following them as best we can
here on law and crime daily
and still ahead here on the broadcast
kobe bryant's widow fights a move by
attorneys for los angeles county to move
her lawsuit against the sheriff's
department to a new court system
plus rap artists offset detained by the
police
we'll tell you who's in trouble with the
law and why when we return
[Music]
legal troubles to report involving
celebrities and at least one of their
attorneys brian buckmeyer bring us up to
date on these cases of course erin so
a lawsuit filed by the widow of nba star
kobe bryant may be heard
in federal court vanessa bryant filed
the case accusing sheriff's deputies of
taking
unauthorized close-up photos of the
scene where her husband
daughter and others died attorneys for
los angeles county
say they want the case in federal court
because it involves the 14th amendment
claims those can be heard by state
courts so vanessa bryant
wants the case held back in the state
court level
a judge has thrown an attorney for actor
johnny depp
off a divorce case between depp and
actress amber hurd
a virginia judge says the attorney
leaked information to the press
which was supposed to be protected under
a court order attorneys for heard have
moved for sanctions against the attorney
the leaks are alleged to have involved
audio recordings surveillance pictures
and witness statements though depp's
attorney is off the case
the judge refused to issue a gag order
rapper offset
has uploaded a recording of himself
being detained
by beverly hills police officers who at
one point hauled him out of his car
the police say a person in his car now
believed to be cardi b's cousin
pointed a gun at someone during a rally
in a support
of president trump a license plate
number and a witness description of the
vehicle involved
led the police to offset the police say
that despite some confusion in the media
offset was not charged i appreciate
those updates brian
famous civil rights attorney ben crump
is now representing the family of the
young woman
shot by police in waukegan illinois the
woman's boyfriend
seen here was killed shooting has
already sparked some protests in that
city
trump says his law firm is beginning its
own investigation into the matter
because they do not trust the police
narrative
the police say they were tracking down a
so-called suspicious vehicle
when it backed up a responding officer
felt in danger and opened fire
krump says that over and over the
official report when police kill black
people
contains missing facts or misrepresents
details the convicted ringleader of a
so-called sex cult is on the eve of
sentencing saying
he's innocent prosecutors say keith
renee was in a
charge of a group called nexium the
self-proclaimed self-help group
had an inner society prosecutor say
actress alison mack and an heir to the
seagram's liquor fortune were part of
the group
a federal jury convicted reneer of seven
counts involving
conspiracy racketeering sex trafficking
attempted sex trafficking
forced labor and even wire fraud but
reneer had these words to nbc news
yes i am innocent and
although it is this is a horrible
tragedy
with many many people being hurt i think
the main thrust of this has been the
oppression
but really a different issue which is
hard for me to express
there is a horrible injustice here and
whether you think i'm the devil or not
the justice process has to be examined i
apologize for my
participation in all of this this pain
and suffering i've clearly participated
i've been the leader of the community
okay we've got to talk about this terry
this is a big case what did you make of
the words there of the alleged
ringleader you know he was convicted of
sex trafficking and other charges and
he's facing life behind bars
i really think frankly he should receive
the maximum he took advantage
of very vulnerable underage girls and
women
and you know he held them against their
will so it's a heinous crime
he was convicted before a jury of his
peers and i think he
really should serve the maximum here
brian
do you counsel your clients to do phone
interviews
to tv networks professing their
innocence right before a federal judge
is about to hand down a sentence the
answer obviously is no no
the the answer is obviously you know
aaron you do not do that and for this
simple distinction anything you as a
defendant says can be picked apart
he used the word oppression oh he thinks
he's being oppressed let's twist that
around
but anything that i say as your defense
accounts counsel
is an argument and you're protected
allow me to say those words some of them
were great but a lot of them can be
twisted or hurt him
he also admitted some degree of
something in there
it wasn't working looking at his words
and maybe he
kind of sort of said it you don't want
what aaron kelly's doing right now for
your client okay i'm the wrong
example here so terry be the prosecutor
if you're the prosecutor how do you
argue this in front of the judge do you
bring this up
i would bring it up frankly i mean he's
out there making statements that it can
be used against him it's an admission i
would definitely bring it up i mean at
this point why not
yeah i mean and brian i think you agree
you know if you're the prosecutor bring
it up say well you know your honor um
we may hear some tale of woe and and
some tale of concern and
and uh expect some expectation of
sympathy here but uh
look at what he just said on the tv the
other night and those are always going
to be used
against you that's why the miranda or
insane we will use these statements
against you
in court not maybe but they will yeah
this will be interesting to watch the
sentencing go down in that case and we
will cover it here on law and crime
daily and still to come on this
broadcast
the tragic killing of mackenzie lewis
her admitted killer is sentenced
but not before hearing words of utter
damnation from the victim's father
stay tuned for that
[Music]
and admitted killer learning his
punishment for killing
a young woman in utah
twenty-three-year-old mackenzie lewick
took a lift home from the airport and
met up with
ayula ajaye who told police he tied her
hands behind her back
and used his hands in a belt to choke
her
she struggled until she stopped moving
ajay had
shut off his security cameras to prevent
evidence from being recorded
and then he burned mackenzie's body in
his backyard where he hit it
terry austin has some statements from
mckenzie's mother and father
and from the defendant himself terry
erin the victim's parents spoke in court
and said they have no compassion for
their daughter's killer
they asked not to have their faces shown
on camera
i have no compassion for you as you have
no compassion for my daughter
it comforts me to know that you will not
no longer be a threat
i sleep better knowing that you're sorry
i just spent every waking hour
looking over your shoulder just waiting
for the final strike
i can only hope for to be slow painful
death my daughter mckenzie looked like a
sweet
amazing young lady with the world ahead
of her she was a kind-hearted person
that cared about others i wanted to help
whoever she did
now i will not have the opportunity to
see her blossom in life
and share her life as a father shit
i feel the loss for all the people in
her life would have touched
she was such a loving caring daughter
sister niece cousin and friend this
sentence today will not bring back
mckenzie
but it's my hope that it will keep this
defendant out of the public eye
and from being able to commit such a
heinous crime again
the defendant spoke in court and
apologized to the victim's parents
mr mrs lewis i'm sorry for what i did
and i just have what i get i decide what
i'm
going to get and i know this one bring
that back
oh i pray that you
that god you what i did to you
back the judge's final sentence and
words from our expert who reviewed
mackenzie lewis autopsy report
we're back with his findings right after
this
[Music]
we're back with more in the murder of
mackenzie lewis where the judge
sentenced the defendant to the maximum
sentence life in prison without
any chance of parole ensuring the
defendant will never be
the released surrounding the death of ms
lewis
beginning with the planning of her
murder
the murder itself and the manner in
which it was committed
the desecration of her body afterwards
shows the type of extreme cruelty and
depravity that calls for nothing less
than
consecutive sentences these crimes and
the defendant's conduct
are the worst of the worst so these
consecutive sentences
that are imposed today may be more
symbolic
of society's intolerance for these types
of
crime and conduct when considering that
it will not necessarily add
time to a life without parole sentence
they are nonetheless appropriate for the
victims and their families and
recognition of their devastating losses
professor of forensics and law and crime
expert joseph scott morgan took a look
over the autopsy report and called this
a vicious killing
he just didn't choke her he flipped her
over
on her stomach and then used a ligature
with a belt and choked her out from the
rear like this
he purposed in this case uh to kill her
i believe
and also to cover up his crime he went
to great great lengths to do this you
know initially he buried the body in the
in the backyard
then he burned her and then when he
sensed that the investigators were on to
him
he transported her to a very remote
location
in a canyon they found child porn in his
possession and i think
that that this goes to kind of a thread
that runs through a lot of these uh
behavioral driven things yeah
you know they say that you know it
wasn't about money it wasn't about
revenge it wasn't
some kind of interaction they've never
met before he was uh
powered i think uh as a result of this
kind of
lust killing uh that was going on and
that's what this kind of comes down to
and it's
it's some of the most uh ferocious
killings
that you can work as an investigator
joseph said that well this is disgusting
it's sickening
let's jump in for some analysis right
now brian from a defense standpoint
we see this tactic from time to time a
defendant agrees to plead guilty to life
in prison
in return for prosecutors taking the
death penalty off the table
it sounds like the evidence in this case
was so planned so premeditated
and so strong that there were few other
options for the defense
so it's not just when the evidence is
strong oftentimes you'll see your
defense attorney and it's kind of the
dirty little secret that we all don't
like to
accept as defense attorneys but often
times the plea
has less um downfalls than the actual
case itself when going to trial so even
if it was a 50 50 chance you turn around
and tell your client
if you go down on this you could face 10
15 20
even the death penalty uh but if you
take this plea i can save your life and
oftentimes
that's what you find clients doing it's
the possible best option here now terry
heartbreaking statements from the family
in utah we have to point this out
mackenzie lewis family had a right to
give those statements under section 1
article 28 of the state constitution
well that's right and it is a
heartbreaking case but what the
constitution
says there in the state of utah is that
the victims have
certain rights and those rights include
being treated
fairly with respect with dignity and i
think that's important
they also have the right to be heard so
these sort of victim impact statements
and you know finally and this is
important too the judge
has to listen and consider the
information
that these victims are giving about the
criminal who has been convicted so it's
an important
section of the constitution certainly
certainly and more and more states are
adopting provisions such as that one
appreciate your time here on the law and
crime network brian and terry and thank
you for watching law on crime daily
we'll see you next time for our
discussions about justice in america
[Music]
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre
law and crime is the only network that
has it all good evening and welcome this
is a complicated case
don't really jump to conclusions we
break down the case of a serial killer
another day of drama between both sides
from multiple live trials daily to
original and compelling programming
the law on crime network is everywhere
and we invite you
inside the jury box this is law and
crime
[Music]
[Music]
you